hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
this video is based on microsoft azure
certifications
microsoft azure is a cloud provider that
holds the second highest market share in
the us
after amazon web services according to
quickstart.com
plenty of companies are switching to
microsoft azure
this proves that companies across the
world embrace the cloud computing
which means the popularity of microsoft
azure services
and azure professionals is on the rise
the salaries of azure professionals are
pretty much higher
compared to professionals working on
other technologies
in the united states of america salaries
of azure developers
range from 1 lakh 15 000
to 1 lakh 75 000 us dollars
so you're thinking about taking up an
azure cloud certification
in that case i could definitely help you
in this video i'll be talking about
azure certifications
which will help you grow your career
some of you must be wondering
which certification is the right choice
for your career
don't worry we will be discussing that
as well in this session
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit that bell
icon to never miss an update
from simply learn coming back to the
topic
let me tell you that microsoft azure
certification consists of 13
certificates and all these
certifications are organized
into four levels fundamental level
associate level
expert level and specialty level
now let's get started with the first
certification
azure fundamental exam ac
900 this is a very basic level of
certification for candidates
who are willing to begin their career in
azure cloud computing
now the skills covered in this
certificate are
core azure concepts like high
availability
ha scalability fault tolerance
ft disaster recovery scalability of
applications and the difference between
cap x and
op x capx is defined as
a business expenses and opex is the
operation cost
next is deep understanding of relational
and non-relational data on azure
then comes analytics workloads modern
data warehousing and
assure architectural components on azure
then knowledge of data injection data
visualization
as your firewall ddos protection and
network security group
now moving forward it's time to know the
important details
of this examination coming to
prerequisites
there are no prerequisites for this
certification which means
it is launched especially for
non-techies
next this exam consists of 30 to 40
questions
which should be answered within 60
minutes the minimum passing score
required for this certification
is 700 points and finally
comes the cost the cost for this
certification is
99 us dollars moving forward
let's talk about our next certification
which is
microsoft certified azure ai
fundamentals exam
ai 900 beta
this certification is designed for
individuals who are willing to learn the
basic knowledge of
how to implement artificial intelligence
machine learning
on microsoft azure let us talk about the
topics covered in this certification
understanding the core concept and
features of common artificial
intelligent workloads and
guiding principles of ai basic principle
of machine learning on azure and
features of computer vision workloads on
azure
next comes the process of identifying
common types of computer vision solution
knowledge of azure tools and services
for computer vision tasks
then it is important to understand the
concept of azure tools and services
for nlp workloads which is covered in
this certification
next is conversational ai workloads on
azure
finally it involves the process of
identifying common use cases
for conversational ai azure services
now moving forward it's time to know the
important details of this examination
for this certification there are no
prerequisites
and the cost of completing this
certificate is 99
next we will talk about the third
certification
that is microsoft certified azure data
fundamentals exam
dp 900 beta
the certification will give the
knowledge of core database concepts such
as
relational and non-relational databases
so that
they can be implemented on microsoft
azure architecture
now let us jump right into the topics
covered in this certification
first the exam covers the core data
workloads
batch and streaming data of data
analytics
next it has the concept of relational
azure data services
such as comparison of p a
a s i a a s and
s a a s delivery models then comes
identification of
fundamental management tasks of
relational database and
various techniques in describing query
techniques
for data using sql language
next comes the concept of non-relational
database workloads
and non-relational data offerings on
azure
then it covers the analytics workloads
and
components of modern data warehouse now
moving forward it's time to know the
important details of this examination
the certificate requires no
prerequisites
next the cost the cost for this
certification
is 99 american dollars now talking about
the next
service that is the microsoft azure
administrator
associate exam ac 103
it is an associate level microsoft azure
certification
it trains a candidate by improvising an
individual skill in implementing
monitoring and managing azure services
so let's jump right into the topics
covered in this certification
it helps in understanding the management
of azure resources
groups and role-based access next
creating and configuring storage
accounts azure files
and azure backup concepts are explained
then the concept of deploying and
managing virtual machines
and vm backups are covered
next comes the concept of configuration
and management of visual networks
implementation of azure load balancer
and network security group
finally it also covers the concept of
creating and managing
azure active directory ad objects
users and groups talking about the exam
details
this exam requires completion of
microsoft azure fundamentals exam
ac900 the exam consists of 40 to 60
questions
which should be answered within 150
minutes a minimum passing score for this
certification is
150 and talking about the cost
the completion of this certification is
160 american dollars
so going further let's talk about the
next certification
microsoft certified azure administrator
associate exam
ac 104 beta
this exam is conducted for the
candidates who know the configuration
and management of compute
storage and virtual networking azure
services
so let's jump right into the topics
covered in this certification
it has concepts of azure ad objects
role-based access control
next it explains how to manage storage
accounts and data in azure storage and
covers the different ways to configure
azure files and azure blob storage then
it shows how to create and configure vms
containers
and web applications on azure platform
finally it explains the concept of
configuration and management of
virtual networking now moving forward
it's time to know the important details
of the examination
this examination has only one
prerequisite that is completion of
azure fundamentals exam ac 900
the cost for this certification is 165
american dollars
did you know that exam az104 is
updated version of certificate az103
after completing this certificate an
azure administrator
is given the responsibility of
implementing azure based
cloud infrastructure our next
certification is microsoft certified
azure developer
associate exam az203
this exam is created for the candidates
who have the knowledge of designing
building and maintaining azure
applications and services
with the coordination of cloud database
administrators
now let's see the topics covered in the
certification
first it covers the concept of building
as your resource manager templates
then it explains simple ways of
monitoring and implementing
batch jobs next it involves the concept
of building azure app services like
web and mobile application api
applications
and implementation of azure functions
then comes the main concept it explains
how to develop
solutions for usage of storage tables
blob storage
cosmos db storage and relational
databases
finally it helps in learning the process
of implementing azure security in terms
of user authentication
user access control and data security if
getting your learning started is half
the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on the screen
talking about prerequisites this
certification requires completion of
microsoft azure fundamentals exam
ac 900 and the exam will have
40 to 60 questions which should be
answered within 180 minutes
and finally comes the cost the cost of
this certification is
160 american dollars
next comes microsoft certified azure
security engineer
associate exam ac 500
this certification helps an individual
to master the knowledge of implementing
and
managing security protocols apart from
that
it also includes the concept of identity
and access management of
cloud security data so let's jump right
into the topics covered in this
certification
it covers the concept of the
configuration of azure ad privileged
identity management
and azure security next it helps an
individual
to learn how to implement management
security and
container security on the applications
on azure platform
next an individual can gain a deep
understanding of concept of azure log
analytics
security alerts and security policies
finally the process of configuration and
security management
of data infrastructure ssl
tls for application is explained
now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on the screen
this certification too requires the
completion of microsoft azure
fundamentals exam
az900 and the exam has a set of
40 to 60 questions which should be
answered within 150 minutes
talking about the cost the cost for this
certification will be
165 american dollars also
this exam requires strong skills in
automation and scripting
a deep understanding of virtualization
technology and
virtual networking and a strong
familiarity with microsoft cloud
services and products
moving further let's see what our next
certification is
it is asia ai engineer associate exam
ai 100 this certification is conducted
for candidates who have a deep
understanding of nlp
natural language processing speech
computer vision bots and
agents using cognitive services
now it's time to dive deep into the
topics covered in this certification
first it has the concepts of ai models
and services
and identifying automation requirements
then comes the process of how to design
a strategy for ingesting and address
data
pipelines for artificial intelligence
applications
and different ways of implementing ai
solutions in
a suitable project next is ai concepts
it helps an individual understand how to
develop ai pipelines and implement ai
workflow finally the management process
this certification involves the process
of monitoring artificial intelligence
components
for continuous improvements candidates
appearing for this exam must have a
basic knowledge of artificial
intelligence
should know which ai tools should be
used in the projects
and should have problem solving skills
in order to meet the project's
performance requirements
this certification requires completion
of microsoft azure fundamentals exam
az900 like the previous certification
the exam consists of 40 to 60 questions
which should be answered within 180
minutes
and finally comes the cost the cost for
this certification will be 165 american
dollars
now let's see what the next
certification
is well it's the microsoft azure data
engineer
associate exams dp200 and dp201
let's talk about the microsoft azure
data engineer associate exam dp200
this exam is designed for candidates who
want to improve their skills and
management
development and data processing now it's
time to dive deep into the topics
covered in the certification
it helps an individual to understand how
to implement relational
and non-relational data storage
solutions next
the certification helps in understanding
the concept of managing data security
by implementing data masking and
encrypting data in the process
then the certification helps an
individual to gain knowledge in
development
streaming and batch processing solutions
finally comes the monitoring process
and individual learn how to monitor data
storage and
few simple ways of implementing data
processing systems
and how to optimize azure data solutions
in a business
now let's talk about the details as you
can see on the screen
this certification requires completion
of microsoft azure fundamentals exam
az900 the exam consists of 40 to 50
questions
which should be answered within 180
minutes not talking about the cost
a candidate will have to pay 165
american dollars
as the exam fee next let's talk about
the exam
dp201 which is launched for designing an
hrd resolution this is the second exam
for
becoming an azure data engineer it helps
candidates to improve their skills in
designing data storage models
mastering the concept of data processing
and data security for azure services
now it's time to dive deep into the
topics covered in the certification
first comes the implementation of
relational and non-relational cloud data
storage and
applications next is the designing
techniques for real-time and
batch processing solutions and provision
of compute
resources then it has the concept of
designing security solutions such as
encryption
auditing and privacy of data finally
it is the design data retention policies
and plan
archiving strategies
now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on the screen
for the certification completion of
microsoft azure fundamentals xam
ac900 next the exam consists of 40 to 50
questions
which should be answered within 150
minutes and finally comes the cost
the cost of this certification will be
american dollars while appearing for
this exam
candidates must have an understanding of
designing azure sql databases
azure cosmos db azure data lake storage
azure stream analytics and blob storage
services
okay now let's see what is the next
certification to discuss
its azure database administrator
associate exam
dp300 beta this exam is ideal for
professionals who are willing to gain
knowledge on
administering cloud-based database
systems
now it's time to dive deep into the
topics covered in the certification
first it consists of the basic concept
of implementing appropriate database
solutions on selected platforms
next it tells how to implement an azure
80 authentication service
on a running application then it
explains about monitoring activities
basic concepts of how to configure
resources to achieve an optimal
performance
next it teaches how to review queries
and database tables
finally it explains the planning and
implementation strategy
for continuous and backup services at
the time of disaster recovery
now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on my screen
there are no prerequisites for this
certification talking about the cost
the exam fee is 165 american dollars
moving further let's discuss what a
microsoft
azure solutions architect expert exam ac
300 and ac 301
are basically these are expert level
microsoft azure certifications
to become an azure certified solutions
architect you have to pass two
examinations
ac300 and ac301
let's first talk about exam ac 300
microsoft azure architect technologies
this exam is suitable for architects who
are the advocate
for their business to achieve this
certification
an individual should have advanced
knowledge in id operations
including virtualization data security
networking and
business continuity now it's time to
dive deep into the topics covered in
this certification
first comes the concept of analyzing
resource utilization
and management of azure active directory
next comes
how to migrate an application to azure
and different ways to manage
role-based access then it explains how
to build configure and run apps in
azure capability service aks finally
it explains how to implement mfa that is
multi-factor authentication for users on
azure platform
now let's discuss the examination
details as you can see on my screen
for the certification completion of
microsoft azure fundamentals exam
az-900 is necessary
next the exam consists of 40 to 60
questions
which should be answered within 150
minutes and finally
comes the cost the cost of the
certification will be
165 american dollars
next exam is ac301
microsoft azure architect design
this is the next expert level exam
suitable for
azure solutions architect to achieve
this certification
the candidate should have complete
knowledge in various aspects of
id fields now it's time to dive deep
into the topics covered in the
certification
to achieve this certification a person
should know how to plan
networking and monitoring strategy based
on client requirement
he should be able to collect data and
infrastructure requirements
and define logical groupings
he should be proficient in designing
data flows and data protection
strategies
you should know about site recovery and
data archiving
now let's discuss the examination
details as you can see on my screen
first comes prerequisites the
certification requires completion of
microsoft azure fundamentals exam ac 900
next this exam consists of 40 to 60
questions
which should be answered within 150
minutes and finally comes to cost
the cost for this certification will be
165
american dollars next comes the last
certification that is
microsoft azure devops engineer expert
exam
az-400 this certificate is
suitable for id professionals who want
to become
asha devops engineer expert
now it's time to dive deep into the
topics covered in this certification
to achieve this certification a person
should know how to design a secure
devops
development lifecycle and tool
integration process
an individual will learn how to
implement version control
on the project and manage to build
infrastructure
next an individual will be able to
analyze and manage
and assure community service
infrastructure
then he will be able to implement
infrastructure
as code compliance and security of the
infrastructure
now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on my screen
this certification does not require
completion of ac 900 certification
but requires the completion of azure
administrator associate
or azure developer associate
certification
the candidate should have a general
knowledge of devops concepts
the exam consists of 40 to 60 questions
which should be answered within 180
minutes
and finally comes the cost the cost of
this certification will be
165 american dollars
this was all about azure certification
now you might have a clear understanding
of
different certifications that microsoft
azure has to offer
and you can go for the best one which
suits your needs
on that note check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program on cloud computing
designed in collaboration with caltech
ctme
it will help you become an expert in
azure aws and
gcp this comprehensive career focused
course will help you master
key architectural principles and develop
the skills needed to become
a cloud expert now let me give you an
important information
regarding exam details microsoft keeps
updating the azure exams
which means once a new exam is launched
the old one will remain accessible
only for 90 days so stay updated and
plan accordingly
now we have come to the end of this
video on azure certification
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here